الآن لم تعد مجالس الإدارة البريطانية
نوادي الفتيان الحصرية ، حيث تشير أحدث مراجعة لـ hampton
alexander إلى أنه لا يوجد
مجالس رجال فقط متبقية
في FTSE 350. عدد النساء في
تلك المجالس ارتفع 50
في السنوات الخمس الماضية ولكن الرجال لا يزالون
يهيمنون
على الرتب العليا من  على الرغم من أن زعيمة واحدة من كبار الشركات
التي حطمت السقف الزجاجي مرارًا
وتكرارًا
هي كريستين لاغارد ، فقد كانت أول
امرأة تشغل منصب وزيرة المالية
في دولة من دول
مجموعة السبع والمديرة الإدارية لصندوق النقد الدولي
والآن بالطبع رئيسة
البنك المركزي
الأوروبي وهي  أخبرت ريتشارد أنها
تتحمل مسؤولية مساعدة الجيل القادم
من القيادات النسائية ،
وأخبرك أن آملي هو أن كل هؤلاء
النساء اللائي
ذكرتهن قد اضطررن إلى كسر بعض الحدود القصوى
في هذه
العملية وآمل أن
يفسح المجال  بالنسبة للآخرين ،
لقد أسعدني حقًا أنه تم تعيين امرأة بعدي في
منصب المدير
الإداري لصندوق النقد
الدولي وآمل جدًا أن يكون بعدي بعد
جانيت بعد نجوزي بعد  o العديد من
النساء
الأخريات سيكون هناك نساء أخريات ، وإذا كان هناك
أي شيء
يمنحنا مسؤولية إضافية
لإثبات
أنه يمكن بالطبع القيام بذلك وبالطبع
يمكننا القيام بالمهمة
وأحيانًا يمكننا القيام بذلك بشكل أفضل من
الآخرين ولكن أنا
واثقة من أنه سيكون هناك عدد أكبر من
النساء اللواتي سيقمن بهذه الوظائف لأن
هناك العديد من
الشابات الموهوبات بشكل لا يصدق
وعملنا نحن كبار السن
هو مساعدتهن فعليًا على رعايتهن وتدريبهن على
إطلاعهن على الطريق وأنا أعلم ذلك
بالنسبة
لأولئك الذين  لقد ذكرت
أنهم يفعلون ذلك ،
فهذه هي النقطة الأساسية الآن ، أليس هذا هو ما يسمى
في العبارة القديمة هو
آه في الماضي لم يفعل بعض كبار السن
وما تقوله الآن هو
أنك تعرف أن  أنا بخير ، لقد جعلتها
تتراجع ، لقد كانت عقلية السلم
مدمرة للغاية في الماضي
الصحيح ، لن أنسى أبدًا مقابلة واحدة
في شركة محاماة كبيرة ستبقى
آه بدون اسم وشريك امرأة تقول
لي لقد  من الصعب أن يكون الأمر صعبًا
أيضًا لا ت  ount
علي واعتقدت ان هذا دخول لطيف